WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE GROWING
CRISIS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, MERRICK
GARLAND, APPOINTING A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO TAKE THE REINS OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FOUND AT HIS HOME AND
OFFICE.
THIS BRINGS US TO A UNIQUE
MOMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY, WITH
SPECIAL COUNSELS LOOKING INTO A
PRESIDENT AND HIS IMMEDIATE
PREDECESSOR.
SOME WENT OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
DOWNPLAY TRUMP'S MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED RECORDS.
>> WHAT I'VE SEEN THAT THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT TRUMP HAVING IN HIS
POSSESSION DIDN'T AMOUNT TO A
HILL OF BEANS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT DOCUMENTS
WERE AT MAR-A-LAGO.
>> IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
INVESTIGATION WILL BE A
PRIORITY?
>> THAT WILL NOT BE A PRIORITY.
>> THIS IS VERY CONCERNING.
THIS IS NOW THE SECOND LOCATION
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS IN
POSSESSION OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
LOOK, WHAT'S THE VICE PRESIDENT
DOING WITH CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> THIS IS SO OUTRAGEOUS THAT
THIS HAS TO RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
THIS BETTER NOT BE A CLERICAL
ISSUE BETWEEN THE ARCHIVIST AND
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I'VE BEEN IN THE OVAL OFFICE
WITH THE PRESIDENT, AND I WOULD
BE VERY SURPRISED IF HE HAS
ACTUAL DOCUMENTS THAT RISE TO A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
>> THESE FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
THIS IS MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> WHEN DID HE GET THEM?
DID HE GET THEM WHEN HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT AND THEN TAKE THEM
WITH HIM?
>> ARE YOU GOING TO HOLD
HEARINGS?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE THAT WE WILL
HOLD HEARINGS.
>> IF THEY TRY TO PROSECUTE
TRUMP FOR HOIS HANDLING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AFTER
HILLARY CLINTON SET UP A SERVER
IN HER BASEMENT, THERE LITERALLY
WILL BE RIOTS IN THE STREET.
>> IF THERE'S NOT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED TO FIND OUT
HOW THIS HAPPENED WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN REGARDING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, THERE IS GOING TO
BE A LOT OF -- IT WILL HURT THE
COUNTRY.
>> THAT WAS REPUBLICANS.
NOW A LOOK AT WHAT DEMOCRATS
SAID THEN AND NOW.
>> THE FACT THAT THEY WERE IN AN
UNSECURED PLACE GUARDED WITH
NOTHING MORE THAN A PADLOCK OR
WHATEVER SECURITY THEY HAD AT A
HOTEL IS DEEPLY ALARMING.
>> I THINK WHENEVER CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ARE SOMEWHERE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE, BUT THEY SEE NO
INTENT OF DELIBERATE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE AS WE SAW IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> IF I TAKE DOCUMENTS OUT, I
HAVE COMMITTED A FELONY.
IF A PRESIDENT TAKES THEM OUT OF
A FACILITY, HE, TOO, HAS BROKEN
THE LAW.
>> CLASSIFIED INFORMATION NEEDS
TO STAY IN SECURE SPACES.
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE THE FACTS.
BUT CLASSIFIED INFORMATION NEEDS
TO BE IN SECURE SPACES.
>> THIS IS LIKELY CRIMINAL WHAT
HAS HAPPENED AT MAR-A-LAGO AND
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WHY WAS HE
HIDING THESE DOCUMENTS EVEN WHEN
THEY WERE REQUESTED.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO WONDER WITH
SOMEONE WHO YOU CANNOT TRUST
LIKE DONALD TRUMP, WHAT ELSE IS
THERE?
>> OF COURSE I'M CONCERNED, I
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
CONCERNED.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
UNINTENTIONAL AND OUTSIDE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
LAWS, CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
MUST REMAIN IN SECURED COMPE
PARTMENTS, AND THERE'S ZERO
COOPERATION FROM DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER,
CHUCK SCHUMER, JOINED CNN THIS
MORNING AND ALSO WEIGHED IN.
>> THERE'S A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
IN EACH SITUATION.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
HANDLED THIS KRCORRECTLY, HE'S
FULLY COOPERATED WITH THE
PROSECUTORS, WHEN THE DOCUMENTS
WERE FOUND HE NOTIFIED ARCHIVES.
IT'S A TOTAL CONTRAST TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN STONEWALLED
FOR A WHOLE YEAR.
THE POINT IS WE NOW HAVE SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS FOR BOTH OF THESE
SITUATIONS, VERY SERIOUS PEOPLE.
WE SHOULD LET IT PLAY OUT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO PUSH THEM IN
ANY DIRECTION OR TRY TO
INFLUENCE THEM.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY.
LET THE SPECIAL PROSECUTORS DO
THEIR JOB.
>> NOTICE HE SAID SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS.
YES, THERE ARE TWO OF THEM NOW.
THERE'S THE OTHER DOCUMENTS
INVESTIGATION AND THERE ARE
DEVELOPMENTS IN THAT THIS
MORNING, AS SOURCES ARE TELLING
ME AND MY COLLEAGUE THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO TALK
TO THE TWO PEOPLE WHO WERE HIRED
TO SEARCH FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S PROPERTIES IN NOVEMBER.
OBVIOUSLY FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
ARE STILL QUESTIONING WHETHER
AFTER MONTHS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS FULLY COMPLIED
WITH THE SUBPOENA THAT HE GOT TO
RETURN ALL CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
KATELYN POLANTZ IS WITH ME THIS
MORNING.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO OUR
SOURCES, TRYING TO GET A CHECK
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE OTHER
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION AS
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT THE NEW
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED
YESTERDAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
INVESTIGATION WITH TRUMP, WHAT'S
NOTABLE IS WHAT WE HEARD FROM
SOURCES THAT THEY WANT TO TALK
TO THE PEOPLE THAT TRUMP'S TEAM
HIRED TO GO AND LOOK AND MAKE
SURE THERE WERE NO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AT ANY OTHER TRUMP
PROPERTIES.
>> RIGHT.
SO WE KNOW THAT THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION IS
CONTINUING ON, THEY'RE STILL
MAKING MOVES TO TRY AND TALK TO
PEOPLE THAT WERE WORKING WITH
DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
WE HAVE CONFIRMATION THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WANTS TO TALK TO TWO
PEOPLE THAT DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM HIRED IN NOVEMBER TO SEARCH
MULTIPLE PROPERTIES OF HIS,
ABOUT FOUR PROPERTIES, AND THAT
THEY HAD FOUND TWO CLASSIFIED
RECORDS IN A STORAGE UNIT IN
FLORIDA.
AND SO THIS IS THE LATEST STEP
OF AN INVESTIGATION THAT IS
GOING ON FOR A YEAR NOW THAT WE
KNOW OF, AND IT IS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT DIFFERS FROM
THE INVESTIGATION WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS MORNING
RELATED TO JOE BIDEN BECAUSE
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS ON
WHETHER JUSTICE IS BEING
OBSTRUCTED HERE BY THE TRUMP
TEAM, AND ALSO THEY CLEARLY MAY
NOT BELIEVE ALL OF THE RECORDS
THAT ARE CLASSIFIED ARE ASSERTED
TO BE BACK IN THE HANDS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CLEARLY IS STILL
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE EVERYTHING BACK.
NOW, WE DID SPEAK TO ONE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS ON THE
RECORD, WHO WAS TELLING US THAT
HIS TEAM IS TRYING TO BE VERY
COOPERATIVE WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AT THIS STAGE.
THEY DID SEARCHES, THEY HIRED
THEIR PEOPLE, THEY'RE TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE NOW, POTENTIALLY, TO
TALK TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TEAM.
HIS QUOTE TO US ON THE RECORD
WAS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
NOTHING WRONG AND A PROPER
INVESTIGATION WOULD HAVE
CONCLUDED MONTHS AGO AMICABLY,
BUT OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO
DO AN INTERVIEW WITH THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE HIRED BY THE
TRUMP TEAM PRETTY SOON.
>> IF THIS IS BORNE OUT THAT
THEY DO WANT TO TALK TO THESE
PEOPLE, WHAT'S THE SENSE OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE WITH
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE OR
TRUMP'S TEAM TRYING TO LIMIT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY
CAN ASK THEM?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IS WHERE
THE NEGOTIATION COMES IN.
SO THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT LAWYERS
AS FAR AS I CAN GATHER FROM THE
SOURCES I'VE BEEN TALKING TO.
BUT THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
HIRED TO WORK AS PART OF THE
LEGAL TEAM, AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE DONE DONALD
TRUMP'S TEAM IS GOING TO WANT TO
TRY AND POTENTIALLY KEEP COVERED
SO THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ASK THEM ALL
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY WANT.
>> KATELYN POLANTZ, GREAT
TEAMWORK.
WE'LL CHECK BACK WITH YOU ON
THIS.
THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BIG
PICTURE HERE AND ALL THAT HAS
TRANSPIRED IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
WHO'S TALKING TO CHRIS WALLACE.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING, POPPY?
>> HERE WE HAVE TWO BACK-TO-BACK
PRESIDENTS WITH TWO SPECIAL
COUNSELS.
THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE,
AS JAMIE GANGEL SAID LAST NIGHT,
IN A WORD, NEVER.
AND TWO PEOPLE THAT MIGHT FACE
OFF IN THE 2024 ELECTION.
>> WELL, IT'S WHY WE ALL GOT
INTO THE NEWS BUSINESS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT NO HOLLYWOOD SCRIPT
WRITER COULD HAVE COME UP WITH
THIS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST SO
ASTONISHING AND THOSE CLIPS YOU
SHOWED BEFORE OF REPUBLICANS
MAKING EXCUSES FOR TRUMP AND
PILING ON BIDEN, DEMOCRATS DOING
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE, THAT DOES
REMIND ME OF A HOLLYWOOD SCRIPT,
"CASSABLANCA" WHERE THE
INSPECTOR SAYS I'M SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT THERE'S GAMBLING IN THE
BACK ROOM.
IT'S ALL POLITICS AND IT'S QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY.
YES, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
INVESTIGATING, THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO INVESTIGATE TRUMP
AND WHETHER HE STILL HAS
DOCUMENTS.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE JUST
FOUND OUT YESTERDAY THERE WAS A
THIRD BATCH OF DOCUMENTS, OR AT
LEAST ONE DOCUMENT, A THIRD
GROUP COMING FROM BIDEN, YOU'VE
GOT TO ASSUME THAT THE NEW
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WILL BE
INVESTIGATING THAT AND WHETHER
WE HAVE FOUND ALL OF THE BIDEN
DOCUMENTS.
>> IF YOU'RE EXPLAINING, YOU'RE
LOSING.
AND SO, LISTEN, I THINK THE
VIEWERS AT HOME ARE VERY SMART
BECAUSE WHEN I SAID PEOPLE AT
HOME ARE GOING TO SEE THESE AND
SEE THEM AS VERY SIMILAR
SITUATIONS, AND THE CRITICISM
WAS PEOPLE, YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THE VIEWERS ARE DUMB.
I KNOW PEOPLE AREN'T DUMB, BUT
PEOPLE AREN'T PAYING ATTENTION
TO EVERY SINGLE NUANCE.
WHEN THEY SAY BIDEN HAD
DOCUMENTS AND TRUMP HAD
DOCUMENTS, AND THE BIDEN PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO EXPLAIN HOW
THIS IS DIFFERENT EVERY SINGLE
TIME.
IF THEY'RE EXPLAINING, ARE THEY
LOSING, AT LEAST POLITICALLY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE MAY BE LEGAL DIFFERENCES,
AND I THINK THERE ARE,
OBVIOUSLY, IN THE CASE OF TRUMP.
THERE WAS A YEAR FIGHT WITH A
GRAND JURY SUBPOENA, AND VE
EVENTUALLY THEY HAD TO RAID.
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE NO
EVIDENCE OF THAT WITH BIDEN,
THAT EVERYTHING THEY'VE FOUND,
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT IF WE
FOUND SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T
IMMEDIATELY TURN IT OVER.
IN THE POLITICAL SENSE, YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
ONE GUY HAD DOCUMENTS, AND
REMEMBER HOW BIDEN WENT AFTER
TRUMP BACK IN SEPTEMBER ON "60
MINUTES", HOW IS THIS POSSIBLE,
IT'S UNIMAGINABLE, AND THEN IT
TURNS OUT HE'S GOT THREE SETS OF
DOCUMENTS.
AND FOR ALL OF THE TALK FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW
TRANSPARENT THEY WERE, REMEMBER,
THE FIRST BATCH OF DOCUMENTS
THEY FOUND BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER, WE DIDN'T
FIND OUT ABOUT IT UNTIL THERE
WAS A RESPONSE TO A MEDIA BREAK
OF THIS STORY THIS WEEK.
SO THIS BIDEN WHITE HOUSE WAS
ANYTHING BUT TRANSPARENT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THEY HAD
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.